this is rather exciting because you want
to go after the big guys right so we'll
goes for some of you know what pulls
your part but basically you're saying
you know we're hip or cool and this is
what people want and we're not only
going to do headphones we're going to do
also smartphones yeah we want to own the
whole ecosystem you know to have a
really good juicer experience if you
love music we should be the one that you
should be using and the market I mean
that you know my question would be when
you have apple that's really dominating
that space yes is it really a space for
for a second person or if you think the
market prayer is just going to increase
I mean I think it's like where the
headphones were 67 years ago everybody
has had it because you had to be able to
listen to music and then when the
technology is stagnated where you could
have like both fashion lifestyle and a
better user experience as well as good
music listening then you were starting
to have more fashionable headphones and
i think that the smartphones is in the
area now where technology kind of
stagnated and it's time to have some
more fun smartphones were you also i
mean we're also bringing technology we
have like seven unique selling points to
have a better use me but what i mean i'm
looking at you know some of the
amplifier books at this out now for
example right there out these are
accessories this is kind of like retro
cool yes is this what you're playing out
this is kind of is it the anti apple
that's more sleek I mean we sell a lot
of products at Apple so we I mean they
are a partner to us i'm not sure that i
will sell our phone but they do sell her
accessories but i think i wouldn't see
it I mean when Apple make a phone they
look at the target of fifty percent plus
a market share when we have created this
phone we're looking at a very niche
market for people who love music and
we're happy to take like three five
percent of that market so who are you
developing the phone with sandy yeah we
want you have a prototype which I can't
see yes so I won't ask you and uh it'll
come out in August yes and you know have
you found it
where are you selling it how many are
you expecting to sell we are targeting
to sell a hundred thousand pieces the in
q3 and q4 so it's very very limited we
already sold almost 30,000 so one
pre-order yes I'll fix the orders and we
have demand for much more but we don't
want to flood the market we really want
to be in that cool space and hard to get
a smartphone is difficult because it is
actually it means that technology it's
really a trusted something that you have
on you all the time yes um who's but you
know every everybody's fighting about
technology is like 4k here and 8
gigabyte there blah blah blah what we
are doing is that you know we take a
smartphone by default because your brain
cannot take more technology and then
we're adding feelings you know soft
values to the product with the brand
name soft I mean what's not feeling like
a few things is it you know but it looks
good so I wanted up with me all the time
yeah but packing it's kind of you know
if you put a LG phone on the table I
don't think that you know you get
further with that girl that you're
talking to if you put a marshal for my
smartphone exactly you know okay this is
a pickup smartphone exactly you're
trying to target this is like no I mean
what we did this when we and develop
this we looked at the community rather
than the technology and then if we if we
want to target this community what do
they need so we saw that if we want to
go after the music community it's like
how do you listen how did you perform
better how do you create music and how
do you record better so these are the
soft values how much what will it you
know how much can i buy your phone for
house it's in the 500 vs yeah and and I
and you partnered with who is it a big
company it's it's a it's a you know
nokia with microsoft they had to lay off
some people unfortunately and some
people also left and we got the team up
in
all in Finland so these guys have been
building more than 100 phones together
so we have a very you know good team on
the technology side on the software
we're partnering up with some of the
best in the industry and so sound is
kind of doom the marketing and the
go-to-market thing and and then we have
different partners because when we
started sounded was eight founders and
we think the same hair we don't want to
exclude we want to invite and do good
things together that's a great business
model Conrad thank you so much for
joining us Conrad Bergstrom their
president and co-founder of sound
industries